you got 24 hours in a day the earlier
you get up the more you can take
advantage of those hours your business
will go to the next level
the second you actually beat the habit
of hitting the snooze
if you ever say to somebody else why are
you up so early that is the quickest
tell - you are not a winning player want
to be happy
build a life not just a business what's
up believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's live your best believed life
and learn how to get up earlier and win
the day also if you want to know what
Jocko well like Mel Robbins David gagas
and others have to say about building
confidence and excellence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video
for free to start your day with the
links to join our in the description
below people want to know how to stop
the laziness and they will know how to
stop the procrastination if you didn't
give a [ __ ] what anybody else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
stick with it with Jocko we'll eat yes I
wake up early yes I wake up at 4:30 in
the morning guess what you got 24 hours
in the day the earlier you get up the
more you can take advantage of those
hours the more you get up before the
enemy or your competitor or actually in
some cases your family and friends the
more stuff you can get done before they
all start bothering you what you should
do if you want to start waking up early
is start waking up early you figure out
what that time is for you and then you
start waking up at that time now if you
wake up and it's earlier than you
normally wake up by the end of the day
guess what you'll be a little bit more
tired and then you can go to bed a
little bit earlier and you continue with
that pattern until you get a good
fixated time of going to bed and waking
up the other piece of this is on the
weekends people think oh great it's the
weekend now I can sleep in negative
don't sleep in on the weekends when you
see friend in the weekends you know on
Saturday you sleep in until 6:30 in the
morning well now you're not tired at
night so you stay up a little bit later
and then on Sunday you sleep in until
8:00 and by the time Monday morning
rolls around you stayed up until
midnight and now you don't feel like
waking up early so get up early and get
up early everyday get a workout in take
care of your health I guarantee your day
will go better give it a shot
get some rule number 2 think about your
future self with Mel Robbins your
business will go to the next level
the second you actually beat the habit
of hitting the snooze and so I would
highly highly highly encourage you
starting tomorrow morning that alarm
goes off notice the gap because the more
that you start to play with this
five-second window and you go 5 4 3 2 1
and you push yourself out of bed and you
hate it and then you take your cold
shower and you hate it and then you
don't look at your phone and you hate it
and then you spend the first 30 minutes
of the day pushing something forward and
you hate it but you do it you will now
be able to coach people who do the exact
same thing 2 years from now how much
money you want to be making like no joke
is a Productivity how much money
thousand fantastic how are you going to
feel yes you're going to feel so
empowered I want you to think for a
second about those zeros on that
statement when you file your taxes about
what you took in yeah
now tomorrow morning when that alarm
goes off and you start feeling all the
excuses that come in and that bed is
cozy I know what you're saying I love my
bed too and you then go five four three
two one and you get up I want you to be
thinking about that hundred thousand
dollars I want you to be thinking about
how proud you are of yourself and I want
you to be thinking about how good it
feels to demonstrate and walk the talk
in terms of what you're actually
coaching other people to do and if you
do that and you show up every day and
you think about that hundred thousand
dollars and you think about what it's
gonna be like in two years when you have
turned this corner you will get out of
bed
this is the corner for you yes okay and
the the piece of advice that I gave you
is anchored in a lot of science so when
people think about their future cells
they did this experiment where they had
two control groups decide to put away
money in like a 401k from their paycheck
and before one group did it they showed
them a digitized photograph of
themselves 20 years older they put in
more money because they were thinking
about their future self the people who
were not shown that put in the average
amount these people put in a significant
amount of money without even being asked
to because they were thinking about
their future self I want you to think
about that future self every single
morning and then I want you to use the
five-second rule to close the gap
between the habit you have now and the
person you want to become rule number
three just do it with Eric Thomas and
Gary Vaynerchuk people who look up to
you who don't do what you do you mean
everybody
you mean everybody the like do you know
many people tweet hustle and work six
hours a day like and they asked me well
why are you up so early
yeah let's move the next question before
I get angry by the way real quick I got
angry
if you ever say to somebody else why are
you up so early that is the quickest
tell - you are not a winning player and
that has ever crossed your mind
you lost rule number four get fit and
manage your diet with Robin Sharma guess
when you're a world-class physical
condition you just need Leslie your
metabolic rate is higher you have a lot
more energy a lot more stamina a lot
more Pachi get super fit and you're just
going to need Leslie eat less food
you'll have more energy don't eat after
eight o'clock and eat every four hours a
little bit of protein a little bit of
carbs but the real key is eat less food
manage your diet you will need Leslie
rule number five be relentless with
David Goggins well everybody is
Groundhog Day again for David Gardens if
you pan it down here you see about three
o'clock in the morning and there's not a
car or a person in sight if you pan over
here it's the same thing not a car or a
person in sight people wanna know where
I find my strength that where I get my
strength I get it from a lot of places
though right now this morning I'm
getting it from there's not a month
that's up there's not a car there's not
a person everybody's in their bed sleep
dread and that is a Monday hate is a
Monday and I'm loving it I'm loving that
we're buds getting weaker I'm getting
stronger it's not about the running the
swimming to push up to sit ups
it's about what those things do for your
mentality you don't get better on a
daggone couch you get better by coming
out here and getting after every daggone
dad
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus rule is Journal
with Tim Ferriss
a five minute journal popped up a lot
okay and that is something takes five
minutes in the morning five minutes at
night
another one was morning pages so
everyone from say Brian Koppelman The
Illusionist billions an amazing
screenwriter and producer as well he's
given morning pages as just one instance
so three freehand pages I think he's
recommended to about a hundred people
ten have taken them up on it and he said
somewhere between seven and nine have
had multiple hit shows multiple hit
movies multiple hit books it's a really
impressive action and this is a daily
exercise that you wake up before you get
your day going it's an important that
it's in that window I would say it's
important that it's before you're in a
reactive mode so before you're dodging
bullets of text and email this is part
of a very typical morning routine for
these folks and for me now yeah where
I'll just I will do my meditation steep
some tea sit down with my tea in the
front and the five minute journal or
morning pages and that sets the stage if
you win the morning you win the day
now I've got a really special bonus rule
with Grant Cardone on how to beat the
Sun up that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one which of
these habits will you commit to starting
tomorrow morning number two who can you
commit to in order to make sure that you
do it and number three how will you
reward yourself once it's done
I beat Senate mana I got out before the
cameraman this morning you can beat that
quickly thing up get up before it is
this is your sensor
I'm women man tiny you done anything all
I did was get out of it
[Music]
so drink you know I dress for success
man I got to grab my favorite watch out
[Music]
it's been probably 15 or 20 minutes a
day just responding speech gonna see
that didn't that encourages him he
encourages me it just works it works we
all we all help each other
if you want to know the five morning
routines that will transform your life
check to the bidder right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
you won't have a strategy you don't have
a real plan you kind of just get up and
say I'm about to tackle today raise your
hand for me raise your hand we don't
stop